bueno luego eran medidas de que moscú
que se afectan a polonia y también a
bulgaria que podría suceder con el resto
de los países del bloque no por ejemplo
alemania que es uno de los que más
dependen del gas ruso
si efectivamente eres de la unión
europea- stm que polonia y bulgaria sean
la primera pieza en caer en un dominio
en el que se acabe cortando
definitivamente el gas sí que es cierto
que esto es poco probable porque esto
infringiría un daño económico sin
precedentes aa rusia y hay que tener en
cuenta que aunque ha cortado el gas a
polonia y bulgaria lo cierto es que
ambos países pensaban habían anunciado
ya que iban a dejar de comprar la
totalidad del gas ruso en a finales de
año así que adelantando una decisión que
ya se había tomado por parte de polonia
y bulgaria
danielle el suministro de gas ruso está
generando o sea divisiones entre los
países de la unión europea que necesitan
garantizar no este suministro por
supuesto crea usted que creo que está
realmente en capacidad de reemplazar
este flujo ruso en este momento
la cuestión es que la respuesta a esa
pregunta es que depende depende porque
no todos los países tienen la misma
dependencia de rusia en el ámbito
energético países del sur de europa como
por ejemplo españa o portugal dependen
muy poco energéticamente en general del
uso de los petróleo rusos de los
hidrocarburos rusos mientras que a
países más del este de europa como
polonia antaño o alemania o incluso
italia dependen aún más en este sentido
ahí es donde surgen las divergencias hay
países que necesitan más ese ese apoyo
energético de rusia y otros que lo
necesitan menos pero en general sí que
es cierto que la situación el contexto
global es de reducción de la de la
dependencia de rusia a pasos agigantados
alemania ha estado reduciendo mucho y ya
se cree que los próximos días puede
acabar con el embargo al petróleo ruso y
así iniciar una suerte de efecto dominó
que bien sea dentro de poco o de cara
más a final de año pero sí que parece
claro que la etapa de la dependencia
energética de lan europea hacia rusia
ha terminado insisto ya digo sea de
manera inmediata o de cara más a final
de año cuando se
acabé embargando el el gas que es el el
gran elemento de dependencia entre lan
europea y rusia